today on the Matt Walsh show Democrats
dominated the unmarried woman vote on
Tuesday you can see why the left is so
determined to destroy marriage in the
family also where the results actually
as bad for Republicans as everyone seems
to assume we'll discuss and Joe Biden
considers investigating Elon Musk for
what exactly well he hasn't figured it
out yet AOC issues a public apology for
failing to have pronouns in her bio plus
cops arrest a blind man for having a
walking cane it may sound like there's
more to this story but there really
isn't we'll talk about all that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
with my family and one of the ways that
I like to do that is with delicious meat
from good ranchers as a special gift to
my listeners this holiday season good
ranchers is giving away two Black Angus
New York strip steaks free with your
order these are um two 12-ounce
Steakhouse quality cuts a 70 value free
you don't want to miss this offer Black
Angus tastes better and is more tender
than any other beef beef black angus
meat is marbled in such a way that the
fat is distributed thinly and evenly
this marbling gives it a consistent
flavor that you don't get with other
Meats Plus Black Angus from good
ranchers is hand cut and trimmed by
expert butchers so you know every piece
is going to be Exquisite while grocery
store meat prices are on the rise good
ranchers is dedicated to helping you
save as much as possible if you
subscribe to good ranchers today you can
lock in your price and avoid those
insanely high prices at the grocery
store and you get some free meat while
you're at it so go to goodranchers.com
Walsh and use code wall to check out for
this special offer that's
goodrancers.com Walsh for two Black
Angus New York strip steak takes free
with your order of good ranchers
American Meat delivered
well as it stands right now the election
results as we are told are still
trickling in uh quote unquote
Republicans are inching closer towards a
slim majority in the house while the
Senate still hangs in the balance the
center races in a few key states have
yet to be called now two days later why
is it taking this long I mean how is it
that a state in a modern and allegedly
Advanced country could take two days to
count its ballots and still not be
finished
how do we explain a state that has you
know a 60 counted of its votes and then
you check back 18 hours later and
they've counted 75 percent of their
votes how could this slow pace possibly
be justified especially when States like
Florida with far more ballots to count
managed to get them all tallied in like
five hours
well it makes sense once you understand
the process and I think a lot of people
don't understand the process there's a
lot of misinformation so in in Arizona
for example
takes a long time in Arizona but what
happens is each individual ballot has to
be ferried up a Mountainside on the back
of a goat and delivered to a magical
Oracle who's sitting in a cave who then
communicates the results via a chain of
smoke signals which eventually get back
to the election office which then after
any necessary Corrections are made of
course sends the tally to CNN by carrier
pigeon so that's the system and it's
quite standard I mean how else are they
supposed to do it can you think of a
better one
at least that's the the most encouraging
theory that I can come up with because
the more likely explanation is that they
take so long because they want to take
so long and there is no good reason why
they could want that I mean there are
reasons why they could want it but no
good ones
they don't fix the system because for
their purpose the system isn't broken
it's working exactly as they prefer
according to their purposes
yet even as we wait for the Mountaintop
Oracle to give us the final results we
can we can still arrive at certain
conclusions about the state of our
country and our culture and none of them
are
all that encouraging I'm afraid so take
Montana referendum number 131 the
results here too are still being
tabulated somehow but with 90 reporting
or so it looks certain that the
referendum is going to fail in Montana
nearly a quarter of a million residents
voted against the referendum with about
200 000 voting for it
what does the referendum seek to
accomplish well
it is supposed to guarantee medical
treatment for infants born alive after a
botched abortion so to be clear a
majority of Voters in Montana do not
want to give life-saving medical
treatment to a born infant outside of
the mother's womb they voted in favor of
leaving the child to die horrifically
and painfully
now there are some generous Souls out
there who want to make excuses for these
voters claiming the referendum was
worded in a confusing way
and that can be a problem certainly and
has been in the past with uh you know
there's a referendum and then you look
at the way it's worded and it's it's
hard in fact we had one of those a
couple months ago we were looking at it
and it's just it's hard to tell where
what they're asking you
but you tell me if you're confused by
this here's the actual language here's
the question that appeared on the ballot
Montana this is what it said
in act adopting the born alive infant
protection act providing that infants
born alive including infants born alive
after an abortion are legal persons
requiring Health Care Providers to take
necessary actions to preserve the life
of a born alive infant providing a
penalty providing that the proposed act
be submitted to qualified electors of
Montana and providing an effective date
and any voters were invited to vote
either yes approving the referendum or
no to rejecting it
in these are statements it's an act
providing legal protection to infants
born alive yes or no
I can't see how anyone could possibly be
confused by that
again an act to provide legal status to
infants born alive after an abortion yes
you want to give them that status and
thus save their lives or no you don't
and if you say no as it clearly
indicates in the wording you are voting
to deny legal protections to Born infant
children
a majority of Voters in Montana Montana
okay not typically considered a Bastion
of far-left activism
voted to deny those protections to
children
we can Comfort ourselves with the
desperate hope that these Montana voters
are just incredibly stupid rather than
incredibly evil but I think that would
be a false hope
in fact abortion and infanticide won on
the ballot all across the country in red
States and blue States voters from
Montana to Kentucky
to more expected places like Michigan
and California voted Often by
considerable margins to deny any legal
protections to children born and unborn
that's the fact of the matter
it's not fun to consider but it is a
fact all the same
there there is definitely we cannot deny
a candidate quality problem in the
Republican party but there is also I'm
afraid to say
a voter quality problem
now the results of these referendums and
of the races themselves can largely be
explained by and uh blamed on I suppose
to often overlapping groups and that
would be gen Z and unmarried women
now it's been widely discussed and as
comes as a surprise to know and I assume
that Democrats won the Gen Z vote by
about two to one
but the unmarried woman factor is I
think most notable as the daily wire
reports quote unmarried women voted
Democrat in the 2022 midterm elections
by a significant margin according to
exit poll data compared to married
individuals favoring GOP candidates this
year a CNN exit poll of 18 571 total
respondents found 68 percent of single
women mark their ballots for Democratic
politicians a 37 point margin over the
Republican Party Republicans gained 20
more votes from married men than
Democrats while single men voted seven
percent more for GOP figures we should
also note importantly that Republicans
won the married woman vote by 14 points
so Republicans win clear majorities of
the married vote and still a slim
majority of the married man of the
rather unmarried man vote
but unmarried women swing heavily to
Democrats
based on this we can also assume that
they are largely responsible for these
ballot measures and shrining abortion
and infanticide across the country I
mean that's why these that's why these
measures passed or didn't pass as the
case may be
um the good news for for you know
Democrats is that the number of
unmarried women in the country continues
to increase year over year
in the middle of the previous Century so
around 1940 1950 a vast majority of the
households in the country 80 or so were
comprised of married couples and
families they were led by married
couples or families you know 80 percent
that number fell to around half by the
end of the century so around 2000 we
were about 50 percent of uh households
were led by married couples and within a
decade after that around 2020 it felt
2010 it fell to less than half
so now a majority of households are not
led by married couples and this is a
this is a first in in recorded history
and the trend continues rapidly in that
direction every year
this is very bad news for children and
not just because unmarried people are
more likely to vote to strip children of
basic legal protections but also because
the children born to these unmarried
people remember we're talking about
unmarried people not not necessarily
childless people I'm not exclusively
childless so any children born to these
unmarried people by by every conceivable
measure face greater obstacles okay
they'll have a worse time of it they
will fare worse
children born to single parents are far
more likely to have behavior problems
far more likely to have academic
problems far more likely to drop out of
school far more likely to get expelled
far more likely to end up in prison far
more likely to end up on drugs far more
likely to end up homeless far more
likely to fall victim to violent crime
on and on and on
it is extremely bad for children and for
society to abandon marriage
that's just the fact
but as is so often the case what is bad
for kids and bad for the culture is
really good for the Democrats
you know they are the Democrat Party is
a it's a vulture you know it feasts on
the carcass of uh decaying civilizations
now it's easy to see why the Democrat
Party is determined then to undermine
marriage and destroy the nuclear family
you can see why the left is openly
hostile to the nuclear family why they
have declared war against it
the nuclear family led by man and woman
bonded in marriage serves as a blockade
a fortress standing against the left's
political and cultural aspirations they
know they can't achieve their ultimate
ends without blowing up the Fortress and
that's what they've set out to do and
they're already having you know enormous
success and they're reaping enormous
political rewards in the process
now why do
unmarried people especially women tend
to favor Democrats that's obvious enough
marriage and family life will tend to
make you less selfish tend to make you
less obsessively focused on your own
desires tend to make you more invested
in the future more grounded right in a
word more conservative
selfish shallow people will naturally
find leftism more appealing and they're
also more susceptible to manipulation
what's more when you're single you're
more vulnerable and that's more likely
to be dependent on the government
Democrats know this which is one of the
primary reasons they oppose a nuclear
family nuclear families need less from
the government typically and and uh and
therefore are harder to control the more
Reliant you are on the government the
more you can be controlled
the easier it is for the Democrats to
extract your vote
unmarried women in particular if they're
sexually active
you know are going to be more likely you
could the Democrats can get their vote
manipulate them use emotional blackmail
to get their vote with with the abortion
issue
because they're more vulnerable and
because they're not married if they have
a kid uh they're more likely to see it
as a as a crisis you know because
they're not married now when you're
married and there are still married
couples that get abortions which is
hideously evil of course but um
if you're married and you have a kid
you're less likely to see it as a crisis
because you're married and you have a
family and that's what that's what the
marriage this is this is what that's all
about
so what does this mean it means of
course that our political problem is
first a cultural problem
and there is no solving a former without
addressing the latter
and there is no addressing the latter if
we're going to neglect marriage and the
family
you know for decades conservatives have
looked for ways to win the political
game without winning the cultural game
and and they're looking for ways to win
the culture then without defending and
encouraging marriage in the family and
it just doesn't work it can't it never
will
if we want the cultural victory
and thus the political victory
our message should be
get married have kids
stay married
get married have kids stay married in
that order that's the three-step process
get married have kids stay married
more people follow that yes Republicans
will win many more elections
you know if we were still at 80 percent
married households then Republicans
would never lose a national election
again
but more importantly we will have saved
our culture from Annihilation and more
important still people will be living
purposeful joyful lives
which ultimately is the end result that
Democrats are most desperate to avoid
now let's get to our five headlines
the left is losing their faith but we're
not man a core part of that faith is
prayer you know I talk a lot about
stressful things all day and you might
feel a little bit overwhelmed with where
the country is going but I've got good
news for you hello can help you find
some peace and hope rooted not in the
government or the institutions but in
God hallow has over 5 000 audio guided
prayers meditations and peaceful
Christian music including the rosary
with Bishop Baron and Mark Wahlberg the
Bible in a year with father Mike Schmitz
prayers for kids so we aren't raising
another generation of crazies and more
hallow helps you build a daily routine
and a habit of prayer helps me to pray
meditate and sleep better it's a huge
part of my daily routine so get an
exclusive three-month free trial at
hallow.com that's hello.com Matt Walsh
hello.com Matt Walsh reclaim your piece
in this crazy world download hello today
there's a couple other points I wanted
to make just about the general about the
election results
and the first is just to reiterate
something that I think I said yesterday
and that I I say all the time when I get
this question about uh you know what are
we going to do how do we save the
country how do we save our culture and
and um question that's asked a lot now
after the election results but
you know in general it's question
conservatives always have and what I'm
always saying it might not be the answer
people want to hear but it's just the
truth
that this that you have to look at this
as a as a long game you have to play the
long game this is a generational
struggle it is not something that's
going to be one overnight okay if you if
the Red Wave had materialized exactly as
a lot of people expected we had the
bigger Red Wave
would that mean that the culture is
saved hurray we you know you control uh
maybe both houses of Congress for two
years with or with the Democrat
president does that save the culture no
it would it would have done a lot that
should have been done and the primary
thing is it would have delivered the
rebuke to the Democrats that they
desperately need
does that want to save the culture
saving the culture and our civilization
again that's a generational fight how do
I know it's a generational fight because
it took generations for us to get here
okay we did lose the culture we are we
are right now in a in a you know we are
in hostile occupied territory culturally
speaking we're the Guerrilla Fighters
the Guerrilla Warriors
uh in the in the in the culture War
so it is lost we did lose it we're
trying to regain it recapture what was
lost but it took generations to lose it
it'll take generations to to win it back
and not just one generation
I mean look at gen Z dominated by you
know the reliably voting Democrat
what does that mean it means that um the
ultimate Victory if it comes
if we save western civilization and it
becomes a thriving
um
shining City on the hill again
I'm not going to live to see that
and you're not going to live to see it
either
maybe our children will or maybe our
children's children
so that's that's what we're working
towards
we're going to be in the trenches right
for our whole lives
you could be depressed by that if you
want to I don't find it depressing
you know I find it's uh somewhat
invigorating because it it I I know what
my job is it's very simple for me
um this is my right this is my lot is to
is to fight down in the trenches to do
the dirty work for the sake of future
Generations
people used to to do that you know we
used to be a society where people fought
for the sake of the future
you know they they fought for things for
results that they would not live to see
and they were fine with that
these days we want the immediate
satisfaction
we don't care about any victory that we
don't get to see tomorrow
that's just not the way this is going to
be we got to get used to it
makes it very simple your lot your
vocation is to fight that's what you're
here for that's what you're going to do
embrace it
learn to enjoy it
that's what that's what it really takes
that's the uh the the you know the
attitude and the personality that we're
going to need to adopt if you don't
already
embrace the fight and also learn to
enjoy it
um but at the same time I also wanted to
note and and this these two things may
seem contradictory they're really not
but
you know I I think it's also worth
noting that this
perhaps it's not as big of a disaster
for Republicans as it's being made out
to be
right it's not it's not good we didn't
get the red wave those expected in all
of that
but the way that we're talking about
this the way the media is talking about
it uh the way that uh that that many
conservatives are talking about it in
their kind of depressive State it's as
if it was this crushing resounding
victory for the Democrats and it really
wasn't the Democrats are going to lose
the house
okay which means that Biden's agenda is
dead in the water I mean it's just dead
to the extent that it was living in the
first place to the extent that he's even
living in the first place uh so uh
they're gonna they're gonna lose the
house so they're gonna lose that
and what we also know is that we know
about what happened in Florida
and there are other bright spots as well
in fact the New York the New Yorker uh
put out this tweet today in this article
it says candidates who railed against
teachers unions and critical race Theory
fared depressingly well in the
yesterday's superintendent and School
Board races according to their writer
Jessica winter so Jessica Winters New
Yorker is depressed
today because
um yes although Democrats did better on
a national level and in the National
offices than than people expected uh
they didn't do very well the school
board races
they didn't do very well superintendent
races
and New Yorkers lamenting that the quote
culture War tactics in those races paid
dividends
and they did
and so that's why as I was emphasizing
yesterday I hope that the I I know the
Republican establishment in particular
the lesson they take from every election
whether it's a win or a loss or
somewhere in between they always take
the lesson that well you see this proves
that all we should be talking about is
tax cuts that's all anyone cares about
and we got to leave all this culture War
stuff to the side
but yesterday's results prove exactly
the opposite okay in areas where
conservatives leaned into the culture
war and fought it openly
and effectively and had a compelling
cultural message they won okay Florida
again big example not just there
you could also look to to uh Texas I
mean look to look to the states where
they uh
openly opposed gender ideology
past laws or policies
to at least try to curb you know the the
abuse of children that is inflicted by
gender ideology in Florida in Texas
here in Tennessee
Republicans did very well
and then the school board raises most
tellingly of all
or in the school of races it's all
culture
you know it's opposing the less cultural
agenda and indoctrination of children
whether it's critical race Theory or
radical gender Theory or whatever else
you know the the assault on parental
rights
so the message is compelling it can win
even even being handicapped by the fact
that Democrats have a massive Advantage
with unmarried women they have a massive
Advantage politically with young people
even so the cultural message wins but
you have to but you have to you have to
convey it you have to fight for you have
to communicate it
most Republicans don't they shy away
from it and then they lose
because the other thing is that you have
to many voters
they're not clued into these things and
so you can't just expect them to already
agree with your cultural message if you
want them to agree with the cultural
message you have to make the case you
have to make the argument explain why
they should
and what we find is that when
conservatives do that they win
when they don't they lose
pretty simple
you know Biden certainly is taking this
as a crushing Victory as from the daily
wire it says on Wednesday after most of
the results have been tabulated from
election day President Biden declared
that he would do nothing differently
despite voters being disenchanted with
the direction of the country earlier in
his press conference Biden had stated
that the voters were also clear that
they're still frustrated I get it I
understand it's been a really tough few
years in this country for so many people
but then a reporter noting Biden's
comments that voters were frustrated in
polls showing 75 percent of Voters
believe in the country is heading in the
wrong direction ask Biden what in the
next two years do you intend to do
differently to change people's opinion
of the direction of the country
particularly as you contemplate a run
for president 2024 Biden said nothing
because they're just finding out what
we're doing the more they know about
what we're doing the more support there
is I'm not going to change as a matter
of fact you know there's some things I
want to change and add to for example we
had passed the most bipartisan we passed
the most extensive gun legislation and I
don't know why I'm reading I'm
attempting to read Biden quotes rather
than just playing them for you we passed
the most extensive of gun legislation
anti you know rational gun policy in 30
years with anti-rational gun policy
and but we didn't ban assault weapons
I'm going to ban assault weapons so I'm
not going to change the direction
but anyway
uh we're going to restore restore the
soul of the country begin to treat each
other with decency honor and integrity
oh there's that again restore the so Joe
Biden is restoring our souls
because we are soulless and they need to
be restored now it is true that in fact
there are some voters who are basically
soulless like for example the ones who
voted in favor of uh denying legal
protections to infants born alive after
an abortion I mean they are soulless but
uh that's that's a problem that goes
beyond the ability of the president of
the United States to solve and anyway
this President certainly is not trying
to solve that particular problem so
um
what this tells us
is that Biden has has learned exactly no
that the lesson he's taking even though
75 percent of Voters are saying that
we're I'm on the wrong we're going the
wrong direction
Biden and the Democrats have bought into
this idea that because there was not a
massive Red Wave because Republicans
didn't win by as much as expected
on in these National races
that means that the Democrat Party had a
crushing cruising Victory and now they
have a mandate to continue doing exactly
what they were already doing that's the
lesson they're going to take which gives
another advantage to the Republicans
because the Democrats are going to
double down on the wrong they're going
to double down on the crazy
while being more hampered to in their
ability to actually enact it because
they're not going to have the House
Representatives anymore
they're going to double down on that and
that gives us an advantage heading into
2024 so that's another Silver Lining we
could look at
during the press conference was asked
about the possibility of investigating
Elon Musk
for what well maybe he'll explain
and we'll see his answer here it is
do you think Elon Musk is a threat to
U.S national security and should the U.S
and with the tools you have investigate
his joint acquisition of Twitter with
foreign governments which include the
Saudis
I think that
Elon musk's
cooperation and or
foreign
technical
relationships with other countries
uh
is worthy of being looked at
whether or not he is doing anything
inappropriate I'm not suggesting that
I'm suggesting that it works worse being
looked at and uh
um and but that's all I'll say
yeah we don't want to have inappropriate
relationships with other countries he
says as he ships another 15 billion
dollars 50 billion dollars to Ukraine
um
so they're going to he's looking at look
at the possibility of investigating Elon
Musk for taking over Twitter like but
but again what would even be the the
pretense for that he doesn't have one
the pretense is just that Elon Musk is
doing something they don't like and so
they're going to investigate him and
you're sending the FBI after
I mean this is this this we the word
fascism is vastly overused this is
fascism that's what this is I don't know
what it looks like it looks like the
government going after someone
investigating them send the Federal
Government after them because they just
did something that the government
doesn't like it's not illegal
and at the same time I will say that uh
you know look the we know the left
through the government advertisers and
all of that they're putting a lot of
pressure on Elon Musk
and the thing that they're most
concerned about I mean they don't really
care who is in charge of Twitter don't
make a difference to them who's in
charge of Twitter they don't care about
any of the technical stuff okay they
don't care about his relationships with
the Saudis
like anyone in our government has any
room to complain about problematic
relationships with the Saudis
um but that's not what they care about
what they care about is the possibility
that Elon Musk will actually turn
Twitter into a free speech Haven and
allow people to just Express their ideas
and speak to each other that's what they
don't want that's what obviously what
they're worried about
as long as Elon doesn't do that then
they will hold off so these are all just
threats what they're what they're really
saying to Elon is
you better keep the content moderation
policies in place I don't care how you
inform but they better stay in place or
this is what we're going to do to you
and that makes me a little bit nervous
because uh then if you hold a question
of whether or not Elon will succumb to
that pressure or not I hope he doesn't
but I will say that uh and it's still
early on but
you know he's been in charge of Twitter
for a couple weeks now content
moderation policies have stayed in place
as they were before you still get
suspended on Twitter for all the same
things you did before if you quote
misgender someone if you call the left
groomers you get suspended for that
all the accounts that were unfairly
banned still banned none of them have
been invited back yet
and it's not like Elon isn't making
massive sweeping changes I mean just
yesterday he instituted this policy of
uh you know giving the blue check
verification to anybody who wants it if
they pay eight dollars and I know that I
was on this show saying that I think
it's a good idea but I you know my my
thought was that okay you're giving the
blue check verification to people who
verify their identities and so that we
know that these are real legitimate
accounts and these are not Bots or
trolls or whatever
and I assume that's what verification
would be like you have to provide an ID
and do all this and I don't think that
you should have to provide an ID to use
the social media platform but if you
want the verification if you want to be
considered a verified account you have
to go through a process of verifying
your identity that's not what musk did
he's just he's just as long as you pay
in the eight bucks he'll give the blue
check to anyone and so now this
supposedly was supposed to be a process
put in place to Tamp down on the Bots
and trolls he's only made it worse
because he gave them all blue checks and
so now there are parity accounts people
imitating public figures and they have
the blue check next to it it's just like
total uh Chaos on Twitter now and it
makes the whole it's uh it makes the
whole experience
even more chaotic and it makes Twitter
more unusable than it was before
and I know on this show I said I said
that I kind of like the idea of opening
up the verification process but again I
I said that all on on the thought the
assumption that the verification process
wouldn't would involve some kind of
actual verification and it doesn't so
um the point is
you know that not any kind of
urgent national issue I understand
um the fact that Twitter is more
confusing and they're giving blue checks
to everybody you know I think the
average American probably isn't all that
concerned about that but
that's a major change that Elon has made
right away
but that's not the kind of major change
that we were hoping for this so the
major changes that we're looking for are
the the changes to content moderation
and censorship and he hasn't touched
that yet
we'll see if he does but as I said I'm a
little bit nervous about that
um
all right we have some
we have some AOC Clips to play for you
these are always fun so first of all she
issued an apology on Instagram a couple
of days ago
and uh I just thought that I should play
this way here's what she's apologizing
for
oh I'm sorry about that the used to be
on there
go in and check
and check sorry about that
they used to be there I guess they fell
off but I'll put them on right now
so she's apologizing that she didn't
have pronouns in her bio
somebody one of her followers were upset
at her for not having pronouns
even though presumably all the followers
know that she's a woman so then they
know that but they they need her to say
it they need to have the pronouns they
know what the pronouns are they just
need them listed they need her to
uh pay the tithe basically and that's
what they need for they need the virtue
signal and so she apologizes and says
that she'll put it back up
um perhaps more relevant she was uh on
the I think this is what is this The
Breakfast Club
talking about the issue of crime
and uh
she's
getting chicken and egg get confused a
little bit here I think let's listen to
this
a lot of people think that crime is up
when we actually see that shootings are
down when we see that huge indicators on
on the most violent crime in New York
City is down Subway crime is up but
let's also note that Subway crime is up
after they committed
so many more officers to the subway
system so that also tells us from a
policy perspective adding more cops to
the subway isn't solving this problem so
there are other things that can solve
this problem
uh right so add more cops to the Subway
and then I guess she's claiming that
because of that you end up with more
crime
as if what the criminals are looking for
places where the cops are just to give
them a challenge
no most criminals are here's the thing
about being a criminal okay uh not that
I have a ton of experience in this area
but most most criminals are are cowards
first of all okay because you're they're
they're they're victimizing innocent
people that's what a crime is
and also they're lazy you know they're
looking for opportunities they're lazy
and they're cowards
either that or they're insane and hopped
up on drugs I mean they could be all of
those things but um so if they're insane
and hopped up on drugs then you know
they're they're not going to be
immediately dissuaded
just by cops being there but at least if
the cops are there then they can put a
stop to it you would you would hope in
theory and arrest the people
but the rest
yeah if the cops are there then they're
going to go and they're gonna look for
someone out there they're looking for an
opportunity
now on the subway for and and also you
you put more cops there if that's not
bringing the crime rate down in that
environment that might mean that you
need more law enforcement or we might
have to look at are the law enforcement
officers actually do it are they unable
to do their yeah you have them there
there were cops all over the place
during the BLM riots the cops were
everywhere you could you could uh you
could throw a rock and hit a cop and
that's what BL Riders were actually
doing
they're there but they weren't allowed
to do anything they were just sitting on
their hands so you have to have them
there and have them the power to do
their jobs
but also on the subway in particular a
lot of that crime this is being driven
by
the homeless drug addicted crazy people
and yeah they're not going to be
immediately dissuaded by the fact that
their cops around because they're on
drugs and they're crazy
still good to have the cops there though
if they're unable to do their jobs
all right I was gonna play another AOC
clip but I think we'd probably soon
enough I don't think can you see more uh
CNBC gives us an update on Biden's
student loan forgiveness so we know that
these the loan forgiveness was passed
and uh well sorry it was not past makes
it sound like it was legislation it
wasn't it was decreed
and uh illegally unconstitutionally
and whatever happened with that you know
are are there a lot of
people college graduates that had
student loans and they've been able to
pay them off or they've been able to pay
into that principle and and uh you know
and have some Financial stability well
let's find out
recipients of President Biden's student
debt forgiveness plan could see their
monthly payments drop up to 300 a month
in the coming weeks but get this 73 say
they actually plan to spend that extra
cash on travel and dining out and
joining us now is the NBC tech chat
co-anchor gear drop Bosa so Deirdre why
are people more inclined to spend the
money they're saving on non-essentials
instead of paying off their bills I
think we may know the answer
and well that that could be according to
one survey but you know it could be easy
as well for some people to enjoy
traveling and eating out rather than
worrying about the future One Financial
coach tell cnbc.com that you should not
use the loan forgiveness only for
long-term goals your short short-term
self may get frustrated and give up on
planning ahead altogether so instead
they say make sure your regular bills
are paid check in on your goals and try
to achieve a balance that also lets you
invest in your future self
oh okay good yeah well you because yeah
you don't want to plan for the future
too much and that might make you
frustrated and so you really just want
to make sure you can enjoy the moment
and have good mental health and yeah
have a nice night out on town
that's good Financial advice
never mind the fact that you're you're
stealing that money from American
taxpayers so that you can just go and
and uh have a nice dinner or go on a
vacation
like the CNBC is reporting it like oh is
that that's an interesting fun little
tidbit
so we are taking money from a
hard-working blue-collar Americans who
didn't go to college made different
choices made better choices actually uh
many of them said I can't afford college
so I'm not going to go and try to pay
I'm not going to I'm not going to take
out a loan I can't afford
um as opposed to the college graduates
who went ahead and did that
and now we're taking money from them it
was bad enough we're taking money from
them to pay off the financial
obligations you're paying off someone
else's financial obligation you're
paying for you know a commitment that
someone else made but then we find out
not surprisingly that you're not even
paying off that commitment or that
obligation because they're just going
off and wasting the money elsewhere
it's uh I mean it's a it is actually an
absolute moral outrage
taking money from
you know Working Class People
so that upper class College grads can go
on vacation I cannot think of it's hard
to think of something more outrageous
than that
and you know again not not a this is a
feature not a bug
of course the by Administration news is
going to happen they're fine with it
and it's totally predictable too because
this is all this all feeds into this
entitlement mentality
now the people that were calling for
student loan forgiveness in the first
place all of them entitled brats
every single person calling for loan
forgiveness
saying that the loan that I took out the
obligation that I have the commitment
that I made should be paid for by
someone else because I don't give a damn
about those other people
I'll take food out of their mouths I'll
take food out of their children I'll
take food off of their off of their
children's plate
for for me because the commitment that I
made but I don't feel like living up to
so every single person calling for that
all of them every single one entitled
spoiled brats
is it a big surprise then that you give
them the money and they just go waste it
that's what entitled spoiled brats do
and you know something they're gonna go
waste the money and they're still going
to have the student loan which they have
not paid down at all and now they're
going to go back to Biden and say well
we need more forgiveness this isn't fair
you know I took the money I went to
Cancun and now but I still have the
student loan forgiveness so I still have
the student loan I'm I'm crushed by the
burden of this debt feel sorry for me
and then Biden will just give them more
money
that's the way these works all right
this is from the daily wire
it says former president Donald Trump
tried to downplay Florida Governor Ron
desantis's dominant election Victory on
Tuesday night claiming that his victory
in 2020 in Florida
was more impressive than desantis's
Victory last night even though facts did
not support that notion Trump said on
social media quote
now that the election of Florida is over
and everything went quite well shouldn't
it be said that in 2020 I got 1.1
million more votes in Florida than Ron D
got this year 5.7 million two 4.6
million just asking
um and this is you know this is in line
with what Trump has been doing before
the election Ron the sanctimonious and
then he was out threatening to to uh dig
up dirt on Ron DeSantis that's what he
was doing while the election was going
on he was making that threat and now
he's saying I got more votes than than
Ron DeSantis and of course
that's a meaningless meaningless
statistic more people vote in in
president presidential elections than
vote in midterm elections
um actually the the the turnoff for Ron
DeSantis when you compare it when you
say that he was only only a million less
than than would show up during a
presidential election that's really
impressive
but beyond that I know that there are
people in the audience that you you just
you don't want to hear the criticism of
Donald Trump it makes you very upset
um
well you just you got to get used to it
because he's if he's going to run for
president he's going to get criticized
politicians get criticized this is not
2016 anymore we're not doing the whole
thing where you're not allowed to
criticize the guy we never should have
done that at the beginning I never
played that game but no one ever should
have played that game no one is above
criticism and if you're a politician if
you're a candidate if you're president
United States you you deserve scrutiny
um you need to be scrutinized and if you
want Trump to be president that's all
the more reason why you should encourage
the scrutiny
um and when he screws up you should
criticize him on the hope that he'll
change and stop screwing up and be a
better candidate
and so the fact of the matter is here
I mean leaving aside everything about
how he's just like going after the the
most popular and and uh and effective
Republicans in the country because he's
jealous but like just from a just from a
political standpoint from a from a
branding marketing you know that kind of
thing campaigning standpoint this it
just looks weak he looks weak and
pitiful right now because he's throwing
all these pot shots at a winning
Republican while while that guy ignores
him
now it's one thing at this eventually if
they both are running and they both run
the primary they're gonna have they're
gonna they are gonna go after each other
that's gonna happen
um and so Ron DeSantis if they're
running in primary he can't go the
entire time without ever responding to
Donald Trump but right now this is the
smartest thing because he's busy
governing and winning and so he's just
ignoring Trump
and Trump continues to snipe at him and
it looks it just looks weak and uh Trump
cannot afford to look weak that's not
his brand his brand is not to be
desperate and weak
his brand also is usually not to to to
hit first
that's not what he does
you know he usually takes the Alpha Dog
position of I'm not going to go after
you like you're too small to bother
going after you
if you go after me I'll come after you
I'll I'll hit back twice as hard
but I'm not going to just walk out there
flailing around flailing my arms and
hitting everything in sight that was
that was Trump's brand before
and it was extremely effective and
compelling obviously
it's one of the things that made him
president in 2016.
but now he's uh
he's he's he is doing what
people do to him
like there's Trump derangement syndrome
well he is he is now exhibiting DeSantis
derangement syndrome
just constantly attacking this guy while
he is ignored
and uh it it does not look good it looks
weak
okay so the criticism here is this is
not about Trump's being an a-hole like
I don't care about that
that is his brand and and how could I
complain that's partly my brand too so I
who am I to criticize in a fellow a-hole
but it
that's not the issue the issue is
looking weak and pathetic
which is what it looks like right now
and if you do want Trump to be the guy
in 2024 and and you don't want DeSantis
to be the guy then uh then you should
especially
be like crying out right now to to to
Trump stop looking weak settle down stop
this
just my just my advice all right let's
get to the comment section
[Music]
David says thank you for saying what
needed to be said about the voters we
have way too many people voting who
should not be allowed to we have so many
voters who are brain damaged well
yeah and that explains how they vote for
brain damaged people if they're brain
damaged themselves uh well you know
David I've never been hesitant about
about criticizing the voters I mean I'm
I'm open about the fact that as I'm
always
advocating you know there should be
fewer people voting it should be harder
to vote there should be parameters put
in place to weed out people who are
effectively brain damaged
and um
if you cared about your Republic if you
cared about the precious uh democracy
that is supposedly under attack then
that's what you would want that's how
that's how you preserve it and that's
how you protect it
you protect it from the masses of morons
stumbling into the polls having no idea
you know uh rubbing their eyes
at at the sunlight first time they've
left their their homes they've been in a
cave you know effectively
I have no idea what's going on in the
world or who they're voting for or why
stumbling in their drunkenly stupidly
randomly casting ballots like
if you want to protect your Republic
and your democratic system then you got
to protect it from that
but that's not a conversation very many
people want to have
uh two sides one stone says so will
suing the parents prevent kids from
being shipped to California for
procedures you can't sue those doctors
but if you can still Sue legal residents
of Tennessee then the parents won't ship
their children out of the state so it's
Extra Protection yeah I imagine with the
law that's getting passed here in
Tennessee protecting children from
gender mutilation and from you know from
from being drugged and mutilated
as we discussed yesterday that bill bill
won of the session was officially filed
yesterday in Tennessee and not only does
it ban the medical practice not only
does it allow victims to sue
so-called health care providers who
inflict this on them but also allows uh
for kids to sue their parents
two if they're parents
um send them in to be butchered
and yeah I would imagine if you're if
you're a a parent shipping your kid
anywhere and you live in Tennessee ship
them anywhere to get butchered then yeah
you're liable to get sued
Ariana says wow love the look today Matt
clothes and hair looking dang good well
I really wish you hadn't you hadn't said
that because that was the tan jacket I
was wearing yesterday and
um right after the show I did March into
our wardrobe department and tell them
never give me this tan jacket burn this
tan jacket I never want to see it again
that actually those were my words
exactly
and because I think I just don't the tan
jacket doesn't doesn't look good at all
I'm not I'm not a tan jacket guy
and um
you know what I said that I don't like
the tan jacket
and then the immediate question back to
me was oh was was the audience making
fun of your outfit again
and I said I said that's like I'm a
child coming home from the bus stop in
tears your mom's like were they making
fun of you again
probably did they were making fun of me
this is my own decision I I don't like
the jacket I don't make every decision
about what I wear based on what the
audience says and then the next question
was oh so your wife didn't like it your
wife told you it's bad no I'm saying it
this is about my body my choice this is
about my choice about what I wear
I can actually make those kinds of
decisions sometimes
now I mean it's true usually if I if I'm
expressing an opinion about what I'm
wearing
usually it's because my my wife said
this looks better on you so that is like
99 of the time but every once in a while
I actually develop my own perspective
about style and things and the things
that I wear
and this is this is in that I thought
this is the the one percent of times
where that's the case
all right
Fletcher says
bro if Florida wasn't such a
bug-infested hell hole with air so humid
you could swim through it I'd totally
move
yeah I kind of feel the same way well I
love living in Tennessee Tennessee is
great too but um but you know I I
certainly would never I could never move
to Florida even if I wanted to because
of the right the weather just doesn't I
need the seasons
can't deal with the humidity
um
Jennifer says kind of related Matt what
is your take on move to a red state I'm
in Minnesota and it seems to be turning
into a blue deep blue State while
previously purple everything my husband
kids and I have is here family jobs
homes The Great Outdoors like no other I
love Minnesota but get nervous about
where the state is headed but honestly
we won't ever leave our lives here do we
deserve what is coming by not leaving is
there anything Noble in staying
I'm a bit even though
putting aside everything I just said
about I wouldn't move to Florida because
it's too hot uh you know but I already
live in a red state so I don't need to I
I am a big advocate of yes move to a red
State leave where you are move somewhere
else balkanization it's inevitable
and we might as well embrace it talk
about embracing things you might as well
Embrace that
um
you know if you live in it in a deep
blue state
uh it's the the trends are against you
the demographics are against you
and yeah you can stay there and go down
with the ship you can stay there and say
well I'm going to fight for the state
and there might be some states it
depends on where you live
you know Minnesota probably a lost cause
if you live in California definitely a
lost cause
the majority of Voters such as the
voters too but also the institutions
they're all against you they have
declared what they want you know they
want this decaying husk of a state
crime ridden
this they want this crime-ridden dirty
hell hole that's what they want
and so you're around a bunch of people
that this is this is what they want
you're living in their
Utopia which is a dystopia
I think the only way around it is to
move
um but obviously you gotta make decision
you think is right for your own family
and I'm also not one of these people
that's easy I I moved to Tennessee two
years ago uh but what happens a lot of
times people they they move to a state
whether it's you know Tennessee or
Florida or Texas and they get there and
then they immediately complain about all
the other conservatives that are moving
there uh which I I don't do that because
first of all who am I to complain when
someone else moves here what I just did
but also I think it's it's I think it's
it's good bring in the reinforcements
bring in the cultural reinforcements I'm
all for it
now I recently watched Jordan Peterson's
exclusive daily wire plus three-part
series on marriage it is the definitive
statement Jordan has made on marriage
and I have to say it is vital viewing
now more than ever like we talked about
at the beginning marriage rates are an
all-time low U.S birth rates are falling
young people are getting married much
later in life and less frequently too
the left has corrupted our or destroyed
every traditional institution including
of course the nuclear family for those
of you uh man children out there who are
still living like flat Frat Boys
Jordan's got a wake-up call for you and
he says it with a lot more tact than I
ever would and if you're married and you
feel like you're in a rut Jordan will
show you how to rekindle that honeymoon
spark as well if you think I'm joking at
one point Jordan even tells you how to
be uh the and I'm quoting here
lust-ridden god-awful monster that your
partner would actually like to make love
with that's one way of putting it daily
wire Plus members can watch all three
episodes of Dr Jordan B Peterson's on
marriage today and if you're not a
member go to delaware.com Walsh and join
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
foreign
for our daily cancellation we head down
to Columbia County in Florida speaking
of Florida where the sheriff has issued
a public apology after body camera
footage of a recent arrest made by two
of his deputies went viral James Hodges
a 61 year old man from Lake City was
arrested at the end of last month uh
charged with resisting arrest of course
you know anytime somebody is arrested
for resisting arrest your first question
is why were they being arrested in the
first place because in order to resist
arrest the arrest must first be
initiated for some reason other than
resisting it since there is no arrest to
resist until the arrest is already being
made or at least you might think though
as we know
um very often in in cases where there is
viral outrage over police body cam
footage the clip you know um that has
gone viral it's very often taken out of
context it's clipped sometimes edited to
make the police officers look as bad as
possible uh very often there is more to
the story very often the police get a
bad rap based on their response to a
highly tense and volatile situation that
they did not create
very often but as you can see from the
footage in this case
um this is not one of those times watch
yes sir I do what is your suspicion it
looks like you're carrying a gun in your
back pocket I'm stopping to make sure
you're carrying it properly you don't
have to ensure that it's not a firearm
no you keep turning so I can't see it
you don't have to be to me well you're
being one to me no sir I'm doing my job
am I detained yeah you are what's your
name and date of birth it doesn't not
matter yes sir it does do you have a
crime would you like me
all right
don't you know very much
and it could look like a weapon she
asked you to really send it okay now
she's asking me for her ID okay I don't
need dieting a reasonable articulated
suspicion and I have committed a crime
and committing a crime in order to stop
to do a crime sir and her suspicion was
that you were armed okay she's asking me
for your ID well now she has verified
that I am not off right so there is no
problem
you don't need it okay
okay
so from there he's arrested taken to
jail
um Hodges the suspect quote unquote in
the video is legally blind you know it
turns out that as he explained he left
early that morning to walk to jury duty
but then found out that it was canceled
and so he proceeded to turn around and
walk home
at which point he was stopped by the
female Deputy he thought that his
walking stick was a gun now
um yes the stick was folded up in his
back pocket which is not a crime last I
checked but also
even folded that way I'm not sure how it
could be mistaken for a firearm has the
female officer ever seen a firearm
before doesn't she wear one every day
what sort of gun did she think he had
that's all irrelevant anyway whatever
led her to suspect that a walking stick
was a firearm the point is that and and
by the way carrying a firearm in Florida
is it provides you have all the licenses
and everything and and that you need
that's not a crime either but
um the point is that the man 30 seconds
into the interaction
produce the walking stick showed it to
be a walking stick thereby confirming
that no crime had been committed
everything was fine he was just a guy
walking
the officer could have ended the
conversation at that point wish the man
a pleasant morning and then went about
her day that's it that's it there's no
reason to continue this
but her Pride was wounded by his lack of
respect and deference and so she cuffed
him and sent him Jill
it may not appear on the police report
but but that is the crime that Hodges
committed he wounded a police officer's
Pride he also embarrassed her by failing
to have a firearm
um he is guilty of inflicting
embarrassment and humiliation in the
first degree and that earned him a trip
to the county lockup
now of course some people have attempted
to put the blame on Hodges here
insisting that you also have just
complied
and done as he was told but but he did
comply as much as necessary to prove
that he hadn't committed any sort of
crime he had no responsibility beyond
that
the relationship between police officer
and citizen is not supposed to be like
the relationship between parent and
child or King and subject
this is America we we don't have a duty
to do exactly as we're told no matter
what regardless of the situation because
I said so is not valid reasoning coming
from a police officer when you're not a
suspect in a crime
and police officers are not empowered to
punish us simply because we're being
disrespectful
which I don't think he was I mean she's
the one who called him a dick to begin
with
she was disrespectful to him
so that so what he has just endure that
and take that and if he responds in kind
even though he's not a suspect in any
crime they can put him in jail
you know in an allegedly free country
where where officials carry the title of
public servant
it is at least at least just as much of
their responsibility to show respect to
us as it is ours to show respect to them
that's the way this is supposed to work
anyway
so will there be consequences for the
officers in this case NBC News has the
report quote two deputies will be
suspended and a Florida Sheriff has
apologized after a visually impaired man
was arrested last month when his walking
cane was mistaken for a gun the deputies
faced suspension without pay and
Harrison was demoted after an
investigation was launched when Hodges
requested body cam footage of the arrest
Hunter said quote as Sheriff I take full
responsibility for this event I want to
extend my sincere apologies to Mr Hodges
for the actions of my deputies I do not
feel these deputies actions were Guided
by ill intent but rather by frustration
and failure to rely on their training
nevertheless this conduct is
unacceptable Hunter said the
investigation showed that deputies
violated policies uh Harrison faced a
suspension of seven days without pay he
will not be eligible for any favorable
action for two years Hunter said goad
who's the female officer faces
suspension without pay for two days
they'll be required to take remedial
training about civil rights Hunter said
remedial civil rights training
these officers need remedial civil
rights training and yet they still have
a job
isn't that like taking an airline pilot
out of the cockpit for two weeks in
order to give him remedial training on
how to land a plane isn't the fact that
such a training is necessary proof in
itself that they shouldn't be on the job
in the first place
yes police officers are often unfairly
blamed and scapegoated I'll be the first
to come to their defense when that
happens you know that but but that
problem is only exacerbated
by the fact that first of all the hiring
and retention standards in most police
departments are far too low cops who
don't possess even the basic skills
necessary to do the job are on the job
anyway and kept there
that female Deputy is bumbling nervous
on edge undisciplined
now again in in many of these videos
when you're looking at a really hot
volatile situation you've got someone
who's violently resisting you know sort
of violent criminal and then you watch
it and you watch a 30-second or even two
minute clip or whatever and you come to
all these conclusions about the police
officers a lot of times it's unfair
because they're they're in that position
you know and it's like there's it's it's
so it's really easy to money Morning
Quarterback but in this case this this
is a low stake situation there's this is
there's nothing going
fine
and yet that's still how she comes
across
she has no business wearing a badge and
yet she wears one
this is partly due to diversity quotas
but then those are the of course the
bane of nearly every institution in
American life and it's probably due to
recruitment problems and Staffing
shortages police departments are
desperate for Warm Bodies to fill those
roles and that desperation is becoming
increasingly evident
but second there there is simply not
enough accountability you know for the
sake of restoring public trust in our
most important institutions like law
enforcement
you have to make an example
out of those who abuse their power or
who fail to fulfill their most basic
obligations
both cops involved here rather than
being temporarily suspended should be at
a minimum fired
you can make an argument for arresting
them and charging them with false
imprisonment abuse of power among other
crimes
when you have a clear-cut case of
tyrannical and abusive Behavior by a
police officer I mean she literally says
yes I'm a tyrant he says are you a timer
she says yeah okay well and then she
acts tyrannically clear-cut I mean
there's nothing to talk about here
so for the sake of justice for the sake
of Clinging On to whatever Faith the
public might still have in the
institution you've got to come down hard
make an example
okay this is not one of those things
where again a police officer is being
unfairly targeted based on out of
context footage and then the public
demands that we make uh that that they
be offered up as a sacrificial goat
that's not this in this case
when she actually has done something
horribly wrong
yeah make an example of her offer her up
for sure
but too often the wagons are circled and
the offenders get off with a slap on the
wrist if that
I mean were any of those police officers
who stood outside the room for an hour
while children are being executed in
Uvalde were any of them ever fired let
alone arrested
no I don't think so and the answer is
far too often though
accountability is not just a buzzword
it's the only way forward it's the only
way to avoid a complete collapse in the
Public's trust and faith in our
essential institutions
and the only way to avoid the chaos that
follows from that
and so that is why
we must say that not only are these
officers but the sheriff as well
for failing to do what's necessary all
of them today are canceled and I'll do
it for us for this portion of the show
as we move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]